♫ [MUSIC PLAYING] ♫
ROAR is an anthology series
based on the short story collection
"Roar" by Cecelia Ahern.
It's a series of eight stories
that are essentially modern day feminist fables,
that takes the either a stereotype or
an issue that women face in society
and tells that story through a fun, surrealist lens.
Get your little butt off of me!
Are you out of your damn mind?!
They put in front of people the things that
women are often meant to pretend they don't experience.
If I am a ghost why am I still getting cramps?!
I love being able to highlight
the different roles women play in our society,
and their journeys to self-empowerment.
We bounce from Betty Gilpin dancing
in her own sort of manic musical,
to Cynthia Erivo telling a story of maternal guilt,
to Nicole Kidman gobbling down photographs.
It really is a sort of wild ride.
The audience should expect the unexpected really.
Every single episode is so different,
so wacky in a wonderful way.
Are you okay?
I met someone.
Oh my God!
Even though it's absurd and uh, sort of fantastical,
and magic realism, I think it's very very relatable.
A mark!
What was really appealing about this project in particular
was the stories, cast, and the crew.
They're very female centric.
It's amazing to work with so many females on set.
I feel so comfortable and free
It makes the experience different because
I don't know that I've ever laughed this much at work.
It's certainly unlike anything I've ever done before.
Sometimes we're trying to make you uncomfortable,
sometimes we're trying to do the opposite,
but usually we want you to leave
and carry the story with you for a while.
I mean it doesn't even look like a big potato,
it looks like a big turd.
How stupid.
Well it makes you smile, nothing's stupid about that.
Hopefully women can see kind of, their roar,
their moment in every episode.
That in some ways,
you kind of can relate in different aspects
to each of the leads,
and each of the stories that is being told.